president trump has not spoken about
those massive wildfires as he prepares
to campaign in the west this weekend
after pausing for the anniversary of the
9 11 attacks
president trump is hitting the campaign
trail again it follows the uproar
from on the record audio recordings that
made clear he knew early on
how severely the coronavirus would
impact the country
skylar henry is at the white house this
morning skyler good morning
hey elaine good morning to you will both
president trump and former vice
president joe biden took the day for
remembrance instead of stumping
today they're back at it for the
president he's doubling down
on his response to the coronavirus
despite the heavy criticism
president trump is headed west this
weekend kicking off a four-stop run
in two key swing states nevada and
arizona
the president and his democratic rival
joe biden put their campaigns on hold
friday
to honor lives lost on 9 11.
shanksville pennsylvania we mourn deeply
for the nearly 3 000 precious and
beautiful souls
who were taken from us on september
11 2001.
the former vice president was also in
lower manhattan
along with current vice president mike
pence where they had a moment of
civility
elbow bumping with less than two months
ago until election day
and he consoled a mother who lost her
son on 9 11.
back at the white house president trump
announced bahrain is formally
recognizing
israel a month after announcing a
similar agreement between the uae
and israel i can tell you this
tremendous enthusiasm on behalf of other
countries
to also join but that bit of good news
might be overshadowed
as mr trump is facing harsh criticism
about what he knew
and when about the severity of covet 19.
it's a little like the regular flu
while admitting in a march interview
with journalist bob woodward for his new
book rage
that he publicly downplayed it i wanted
to always play it down
i still like playing it down yes sir
because i don't want to create a panic
there were times when i was out there
telling the american public how
difficult this is how we're having a
really serious problem
you know when the president was saying
it's something that's going to disappear
which obviously is not the case
despite the pushback president trump
justified downplaying the pandemic
denying he lied because he didn't want
to incite a national panic
now airport officials in nevada are
standing firm rejecting the president's
plans
for a hangar rally there citing a
50-person
mass gathering because of the pandemic
now
critics say that democrats are trying to
block the president
from speaking to voters but airport
officials say that this is not
a political one but rather a directive
because of the governor
because of the pandemic jeff okay
schuyler thank you very much